hello everybody and welcome back to
let's play followed by dear ok um thank
you for bearing with me while my voice
was gone and and now it's almost
completely back so I decided that it was
about damn time that I made another
video cuz I did not want to eat you guys
held up on Content long ah
all right isn't it thank you wasting my
my mum wasted my torch lantern has it
called it's been so long since I played
the game of completely forgotten one
thing's your fault okay anyway what
happened was um we just got past that
goop and then it reaped the goop rebuilt
it in a box you've rebuilt behind us if
I coughed wring this let's play I'm
sorry but do and won't budge
pathetic oh why did I just lined all
those torches if I wasn't gonna come
back here damn it probably wasted oh oh
not today who that that torch lights it
up I like that
piggies in here hello piggies ooh a
portcullis key is a heavy gate my voice
is still isn't back like 100 percent
obviously if you're listening to this I
think I'm even still just a little bit
quieter than I usually have but
something better nothing right right
No ooh that probably does the port Oh
huh OOP chair how did it get through
there if that landed into here needed
fled mm-hmm mm-hmm
okay nothing better learner okay
Oh what's this all a big news ha ha ha
so sneaky
I shouldn't lit all those torches or any
kind of need to sneak around him now
hurt hurt yeah what the hell was that
why did it is he there
oh no I ran out of it will fire don't
touch the fire but then get right then
ah whistle this kid see a damn thing
he's right there
need to get gone yeah not anonym it's
not oil I need oil I need oil right
big o hate wheels
there we go
how much turning this is needed can't
see thing oil oil candle why did I come
in
broom sweeping up just huh what what you
do
yeah here before I mess you up already
way out oh okay I see lose the way out
so that I can again escape from
diabolical monsters oh oh oh I don't
like that I don't want to go down but
I'm brave
yeah a check come check the distance
what we what what what boxes possessed
oh did you see that it twitched weird
okay it's fine alright I'm okay I like
ladders you know the entire time I've
been doing Let's Plays I've been saying
and there's gonna be some pop out at the
top or bottom of ladder and nothing has
so maybe I'm just paranoid
most the whale call hmm
Oh red fuel rod the Tri cycle phosphate
emitter thing what was that
you saw that right the whole thing just
shook Oh sounds like one of those jump
cuts when things change hello
hello
huh huh oh
oh okay see to the fuel rods are missing
what I got won't fool you
aha go when did I get oil
you remember picking it up hmm
um how does tinderboxes darn it up
tinderbox man I I wasn't hoping that I
would be taken seriously when I said
that I wasn't gonna ruin the game with a
billion tinderboxes now I have run out
hmm actually that is better that way the
game should like not give you everything
you need all the time that's it
don't don't cut me in half bro don't not
cut me in half
I will all out Jack slap you shut up
puppy all right let's just be cool here
ah
coo coo
qu okay my last tinderbox again oh sorry
huh hahaha I blocked it up I'm so smart
was it gonna shut on me really was it
gonna [ __ ] on me hey I got I guess see I
can't even I can't even move buggy yeah
it was totally gonna shut on me but I
broke the game alright I'll play along
as if that was supposed to happen and I
just got I totally got see if I can get
even get out oh hey Brooke the cake huh
alright hello but oh no I got trapped
what do I ever do oh I shouldn't cuz
she's got out
Spyder woods stops wagon shut up shut up
shut up okay making my way down Oh
cockroach mmm
you
hey buddy hey that's it like you got
some asthma you sound like I did after I
lost my voice that's basically how I
roamed around my house discord creeped
out my chairs
my brother
something changed
ah okay that's cool that's cool
that's all cool man
but what what what what okay the way out
is definitely blocked up I want touch it
ow her how them what did God don't touch
it
I'm so stupid really you guys let me
touch it
okay huh oh come on hey stop it - back I
did oh what the hell when entering the
elevator William asked and which way are
you going don't if cursed Francis yelled
back I see it all now
Darren of course any senses like that
Oh
water don't like water my vision is very
red it's for some reason they wanted to
hit me with four hits of the goopy stuff
even though that's never happened ever
what do we got here
nothing hmm huh hi come here I need to
use you for something which put your
call oh it's broken
nevermind you're coming with me bloody
some pie that painting no um look
finally oil I need that ah what we got
here
we wouldn't elephant all right bye-bye
okay and down we go now this is going to
obey rule one two or three
no I love elevator ride in a game can be
perfectly never never ever
I know booth there
probably bad thing decide to straighten
shaving up food
up number one get stuck it's stuck
oh hey buddy okay
you need to try more really
was that guy gonna break in or something
and there
only one of them had the courage to
carry on and he left the others behind
you mean when the elevator broke like it
has before anyway carrying on by myself
okay it's actually kind of reminiscence
of partying actually amnesia whoa
I don't you do don't judge me don't look
at me like that yeah let's stop looking
into ego okay of course the elevator is
like completely smashed up and I'm just
fine okay am I still barely conscious
not healed up a little bit at least I'm
not gonna waste a tinderbox things are
still a little red
um yeah nope Oh Oh Dart hello rat
hello massy massy massy massy here's
June first yeah yeah there's no place
for a little cute squeaky creatures it
won't budge because that lock is in
excellent condition which means I need
to either weaken it through acid or I
need an actual key hose that people need
to shut up out there wha an arm I can't
pick it up see bread two points boom
yeah yeah three points boom yeah so
great look at me
tinderbox and all right I'll play your
game you would dark forces are after you
and will bring sorrow and suffering you
must avoid them at all cost
this is why you are followed by death
David I would love it when any game or
movie uses the title as line in the game
alright but was there anything actually
in here this is the only other room
besides the area with the padlock right
right
Oh God Oh turn dirt yep and then boom is
that just an illusion
hey what did I write what it would get
rid looks like my wife's killer has
returned Oh mousse man killed your wife
that's right it was specifically mousse
man that got him got her I need to tread
carefully okay
you ever gotta mourn the loss of your
wife not think so you a jerk okay
I got a cut it here but thank you guys
so much for watching and as always I
will see you in the next video bye-bye